this is your group right these Indians
right here that's what's up bro that's
what's up stay true stay true stay true
nah
bro who are you Pakistani oh [__] I
didn't know that man never mind Pakistan
Pakistan I'm kidding I'm kidding dog
give us back Kashmir though how y'all
know each other what is that University
of Illinois Chicago Chicago what do
youall want to do I swear to God if you
that's why I'm [__] talking about Premed
what about you government you're Indian
for real how you going to be in the
government every Indian Li on his Texas
and you guys in
relationships what
why yeah yeah I trust you running the
government for
sure